- Charlotte Gainsbourg,
vous avez une carrière bien
remplie. Vous avez tourné
dans une soixantaine de films,
produit cinq albums.
J'ai adoré votre nouveau
documentaire, Jane par
Charlotte.
- S'affranchir à tout prix.
♪ ♪ ♪
J'ai pas envie de m'affranchir.
- Après avoir réalisé ce
documentaire sur votre mère et
sur votre relation avec la mère,
est-ce que vous êtes devenue,
vous, une meilleure mère
et est-ce que vous êtes en paix
avec certaines choses?
CHARLOTTE GAINSBOURT,
comédienne et chanteuse
- Euh, je suis en paix
avec le fait que ce rapport
que je critique, où je...
oui, je fais semblant...
semblant de pas le critiquer,
mais je le critique quand même
au début, en disant : "Pourquoi,
pour i i il y a cette pudeur
entre nous? Pourquoi tu es...
pas la même avec... quand Kate
était vivante, avec elle? Et tu
as pas le même rapport avec Lou.
Pourquoi on est si timides l'une
et l'autre? Et cette réserve,
d'où elle vient?"
Donc, c'est un rapport que
je critique parce que j'envie
ce côté familier, proche.
On a toutes les deux une pudeur
l'une en face de l'autre,
et je sais pas d'où elle sort.
Aujourd'hui, je trouve ça
très touchant, notre rapport,
en fait. Je trouve qu'il y a
a a a a beauté dans ce... dans
cette ambiguïté, dans ce...
oui, ce rapport compliqué,
mais je trouve ça beau aussi,
les ciels bleus. Je me souviens
que mon père, il trouvait
qu'il y avait pad-d-d-d-chose
à dire des ciels bleus,
que c'était plus... quand
c'est ombragé, c'est plus...
c'est plus intéressant.
- La dernière fois que
j'ai rencontré votre soeur
Lou Doillon, elle me disai
"J'ai été élevée par
des parents-enfants. Donc,
j'étais en fait le parent dans
la maison." Est-ce que c'est un
peu la même chovovovovovous?
- Pas du tout. J'avais
des parents qui étaient... qui
s'amusaient. Qui étaient pas
des enfants, qui étaient
vraiment... des figures très
fortes, mais qui avaient
leur vie à eux de folies,
dans les années 70, de beuveries
parisiennes hyper mondaines.
Je suis très heureuse,
d'ailleurs, qu'ils aient eu...
qu'ils nous aient peut-être
dénigrés, mais qu'ils se soient
autant amusés, parce que
ça reflète beaucoup d'innocence
et d'amour, en fait. Je sais
que j'ai des parents qui
aiaiaiaiaiaimés, je trouve ça
vachement important.
- Votre première photo,
elle est ici, sur la pochette
du sublime disque "Histoirede Ms
dans le ventre de votre mère,
Jane Birkin.
-  ç ç ç ç ç ça que son bouton
ne ferme pas. On voit pas...
Il y avait pas de retouches,
à l'époque, donc c'est past t tt
qu'elle a le dernier bouton
qu'elle peut pas fermer.
- Donc, vous êtes en quelquesore
de votre père? Et de votre mère?
- Non, on est quatre enfants.
- Mais, comment vous gérez,
justement, ce patrimoine si
important, les rééditions,
pour que son oeuvre reste
vivante?
- On maîtrise pas grand-chose.
Je trouve pas qu'on soit... oui,
on est gardiens du temple tous
les quatre, on essaie de fai
au mieux depuis 30 ans, 31 ans
bientôt, euh... sans qu'on ait
eu vraiment de mode d'emploi
ou... On est tombés dedans
comme ça sans... Heureusement
qu'il y a, justement,
des artistes qui sont inspirés
par lui, qu'il y a les maisons
de disques différentes qui
reprennent et qui ont eu
des idées. C'est pas nous
qui faisons ces rééditions.
C'est pas... Voilà, nous,
on dit oui, non, mais c'est
pas... c'est pas grâce à nous.
- Je fais
par l'actualité,
Charlotte Gainsbourg, avec
ce qui se passe en Ukraine
parcdsdsdsdsdsdsdsds-parents
sont d'origine russe
ukrainienne. Votre père,
Serge Gainsbourg, parlaient
beaucoup de ses origines.
Il en était fier. J'imagine
que ça vous touche beaucoup,
ce qui se passe.
- Oui, parce que depuis
toujours, je dis que j'a
des ancêtres russes. Enfin,
mon père a toujours dit
qu'il était juif russe.
Donc, pour moi, il y avait
que question d
Aujourd'hui, je comprends
qu'on est pas russes,
on est complètement ukrainiens
parce que les villes dont
ma tante me parle aujourd'hui,
c'est des villes d'Ukraine.
Et je comprend,,,,,,,,,
c'est les ancêtres qu'on partage
avec énormément d'Ukrainiens
immigrés juifs qui ont fui.
Donc, ça me touche énormément,
ce conflit aujourd'hui parce
que c'est un conflit intérieur
aussi. On es
enfin il y a les deux.
Après, il y a un despote,
Poutine, qu'il faut combattre.
s fière et
très, en fait, très concernée
par le rôle de l'Europe et
on a vu une parole européenne
et c'est important.
- Charlotte Gainsbourg,
j'ai bien hâte de vous revoir
parce que vous travaillez
sur un nouvel album.
- Oui. Oui, mais ça me prend
toujours beaucoup de temps, donc
je sais pas quand il sera fini.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Merc